welcome to my room here's my poster of
the Osmonds and over here is my belly
button lint collection
[Music]
I want a girl to be like wait you're
sick how are you still single he wants a
girl that says how are you still single
mm-hmm you're wearing a virginity rock
t-shirt hey mom the ideal girl isn't
thinking that her ideal guy still lives
at home in mom's basement right but I do
would you like to know how badly I want
to have with a girl it's all I've been
able to think about last night
I just like sit there with girls
sometimes on dates like you're the
cutest you're the sweetest you're the
best let's code you want a coke not sure
if you want to go on a date with me
what would a t-shirt change your mind I
made out with Skippy for three minutes
and all I got was this lousy t-shirt
[Music]
I don't even have commentary dad I'm so
confused
what a cut-up are you nice you're so
nice like you like he's suffocating them
mm-hmm and let me tell me about this
like they'll tell you that guys
sometimes will show up on dates with
them and they'll be like we're so alike
you're just like perfect all this stuff
more than the girls do me way too much
it's like when our girls are the first
day so how many kids you want don't get
married yeah yo can we just know each
other make the world a better place kiss
on Skippy's face about the kangaroo
Skippy Skippy no he is tippy oh no no no
we're not even fifty seconds in if I'm
cringing is that my fault
no please put your job you may be
thirsty for some Skippy got Skippy huh
this is a play on got milk
[Music]
no no listen you bring a wig mom with
you when you want your plane to crash
move oh this is not gonna work what is
you doing
you are so weird what are you doing no
no no don't circle around me because I
don't know she has a shirt that says
wingmom bear with me endure comenta my
thousand eight costs tab a song we all
know Carly's the unit is called really
fun time anthem I would choose it about
not my mama she is the body day that you
serve Eichler of Isis ensure leaders I
see some magic or Whaley Popo
let's go sleepy let's go
jealous Suzie be the mom that me tie my
nose notorious the day I got so much
more personality with any other guy in
here like it's a race for number two
because the like funniest the most
creative guy just walked into the room
you know the problem with being this
decision and not being self-aware is
that rejection is gonna hit you away
harder because you don't understand why
anything is happening
you think it's really gonna be the
people's fault and this is the reason
why people schools can we say that
we did I'm 34 years old I'm a virgin and
I'm awesome I'm really awesome and I'm a
good person
and if you got to know me you would
think so too I would love it if we got
to know each other better do you feel
that there is chemistry here right okay
this girls trying to be nice for the
cameras but you couldn't tell she's just
like [ __ ] get away from me
[Music]
yeah yeah yeah
what I'm gonna need a ride to go to the
airport to go to Punta Cana with my
boyfriend he's let me give me a ride but
nobody's gonna ask how fast you need to
get up like Skippy for me right so now
he's gonna suffer from when something
it's called one it is or one itis I
don't know what the word how you say it
out loud
but it's what happens when you only meet
one person and you fixate on that one
person so I tell dudes talk to a couple
girls and then as you progressed and
just pick one out after you've developed
something but initially when you only
have one girl and you're desperate it's
going to be very difficult for you to
not let it show okay stop stop stop stop
stop
you're 34 you could take her somewhere
there's gotta be okay perfect
welcome to my room here's my poster of
the Osmonds and over here is my belly
button lint collection
oh did he say belly button lint connects
man I can't oh this is the craziest
who's ever seen before I give you this
and before I walk you to the door I
really do think that I did pretty good
on this date if maybe if I ask nicely
can I please just give you a kiss and
sometimes you just are home and you just
want a kiss and you want like some rough
stuff but not Bishop not talk to Bishop
rough but you want kind of like stop
that's toxic
she's that's pressure because the
cameras there isn't wanted a slight
borderline aggression that's like
borderline [ __ ] ah man that's just
[ __ ] nasty it doesn't have any giant
that can does that work can I just can I
just give you a kiss
a guy wanting to kiss a girl shouldn't
be a shock to a cute girl it should kind
of be expected right and now you're
gonna try to press her that and now
that's a problem is what I told you
earlier so like guys who are not
self-aware at all who are also getting
rejected all the time or even worse than
the guys who are aware of why cuz he
can't read the cues at all so this is
the kind of dude what'd I tell you
really doesn't handle rejection well and
you're watching that right now I agree
he oh no on the cheek oh you can't even
read
you can't even read the discomfort like
how she's not yeah but when is that on
the cheek respect what she wants she's
that you think can I kiss you she said
there and you thought oh man Wow
[Music]
mom what are you doing that's the
problem there you go there's nowhere
like she's Lionel Richie hello is it me
you're looking like she slid in like
Bobby Caldwell when he revealed his face
for the first time in his music video
this was so goddamn creepy just showed
up out of the darkness
[Music]
that's all forever Skippy gross I can't
watch this
god damn plc's amazing at what they do
there the goats of the cringe Tina
jeez you're entertaining cream stir
taming yes that is exactly what it is
yes yes I can't they're so good at what
they do
I bow down to the live cream stir demon
all right TLC listen Jeff any insight
you wanna add cuz I'm ready to go take a
shower there's none that was creepy if
you made it this far
leave a comment cuz we respect you and
we want to show you some love right what
holy
[Music]
no just walk up and be like son remember
the girl from like two songs ago she was
cute maybe you should ask her again okay
my role is wing mom and it's all kind of
keep an eye on the ladies when I meet
the girl that I fall in love with I want
her and my mom to be really good friends
tonight could be the beginnings of my
start to eternal bliss no it's not it's
not it's not the job of the wing mom
it's data home yeah and stay quiet
wandering the basement
take time to get to know skip you'll
find you really really like him and hey
he might be marriage material
[Music]
Oh Skippy this is our party sort of
there's nothing worse than when someone
tries to show off and they're lame yeah
actually I bought him this shirt
yeah the one that you're complimenting I
if you do want to kiss me my answer is
yes I I need a girlfriend I'm in a rut
in my life where I need companionship
what Jimmy has in muscles I have in
personalities like if friend is trying
to help him even the competition with
his friend yeah that's my shirt and you
like that well I don't it's that it's
that change yeah it's good competition
with his friends his friend is trying to
set him up but he's trying to prove his
friend that his friend is wrong no no I
got all it takes even worse he's
undercutting his friend to make himself
look better yeah you don't say do you
have your future kids names picked out
oh no I've had my future kids names
picked out since I was 14
okay no no you know what TLC because the
way they edit this they made her seem
interested at first and then the moment
she gets there she sounds that's editing
it has to be yeah it's too much what
happened is this they were there and it
was like ah he's really nice he didn't
ask her out the producer went so
Stephanie so you you think he's really
cool and everything and stuff so would
you like you know no film a date like
you don't you want me to go on a date
and get to know better you don't have to
do anything and this is what happens yes
let's go I've got I've got a surprise
don't go anywhere if you want to kind of
clean this up or something like that but
I'll be right back time okay clean this
up you bring a girl to your place you
ask her to clean this up on the first
date what surprise can you come in and
share your talents with us you little
speck Simon Dunne the zombie that your
long said Oh what is this oh I want to
be able to put my arm around her and
just kind of like sway at a concert like
to me that's great and to me that's cute
and whenever I see people doing that I'm
like oh I want to be them
[Music]
oh that was so awkwardly aggressive and
you can tell the TLC guys behind the
camera like we got the shot all right I
want to interview a TLC producer I do I
want to talk to the people if you guys
wanted to do that leave a comment below
we will see if we can make it happen
I'll do some digging but this is crazy